daniel at-il d'albertas chirurgien orl
et président du syndicat smaer bonjour
daniel latine d'albertas merci de
répondre à nos questions sur rt france
votre syndicat est à l'origine des
requêtes qui ont été retoqués est-ce que
vous vous attendiez à cette décision et
qu'est ce que vous envisagez maintenant
saisir une autre instance
malheureusement la décision du conseil
d'état nous est pas disons on n'est pas
surpris de la décision du conseil d'état
malheureusement il ça pose vraiment la
question de l'autonomie de
l'indépendance cette pile haute
administration française puisque cette
haute administration le conseil d'état
se retranche derrière la position de
l'état
bien sûr nous allons riposter
parce que nous trouvons inadmissible
inadmissible la position de l'état à la
fois sur le masque alors qu'une carence
des masques nour nous remontre
quotidiennement par l'intermédiaire de
nos collègues soignants sur le terrain
que très syndicats de soignants ont fait
un communiqué de presse pour remonter
cette carence l'état nous dit on n'a pas
de remontée de cette carence au niveau
de la population sur les tests on a
demandé la généralisation des tests et
on sait maintenant que l'état fait un
petit effort pour généraliser les tests
auprès d'eads et de certains
laboratoires privés
on se pose la question est ce que c'est
pour la fiabilité des tests ou est ce
que c'est pour la maîtrise des deux
nombre de contaminés et enfin pour le
traitement
je vous rappelle que le médecin a une
obligation de moyens et qu' il serait
criminel de ne pas traiter un patient
sous prétexte
et écoutez bien sous prétexte que les
médecins libéraux prescrire et à tord et
à travers ces médicaments et ne seraient
pas capables de gérer les complications
mais où va-t-on c'est à dire que les
médecins hospitaliers sont les seuls à
pouvoir gérer le traitement qui est un
traitement tout à fait banale qui a été
prescrit pour la prévention du du
paludisme dans des années vous n'êtes
pas parler de la prescription de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine et de l'asie
trop micinn vous vous que vous voulez
pour les patients à risque d'un côté on
sait qu'à une nouvelle étude du
professeur didier raoul qui se serait
avérée efficace et de l'autre côté sur
le gouvernement
les études actuelles ne sont pas assez
probantes pour en élargir l'usagé aux
patients à risque qu'est ce que vous
répondez à l'exécutif mais nous sommes
en crise et c on a nous avons une
obligation de moyens on a un premier
test réalisé par le professeur raoult
qui montre une certaine efficacité
c'est à nous médecins d'engager des
études pour confirmer ou infirmer ces
affirmations
c'est pas je dire on ne peut pas rester
en statu quo aujourd'hui je veux dire on
l'a on a le professeur à ou d'un côté
qui dit font traiter tout le monde avec
cette association qui a bien évidemment
comme tous les médicaments un risque de
prescription à risque cardiaque un
risque talbot logique et ce risque
cardiaque et ophtalmologiques
c'est aux médecins de l'estimé et et de
le faire en fonction de son patient mais
on est dans une situation où on ne
on ne réserve c'est traitement qu'aux
médecins hospitaliers et en réanimation
mais c'est par les animations qu'il faut
traiter les gens c c'est juste au moment
du dépistage qu'on a des pistes est
impatient positif s'il a des facteurs de
risque il faut le traiter et il faut le
traiter avant de la mettre en
réanimation
votre autre réquisits autre demande un
de votre côté la réquisition des stocks
de masques vous en avez parlé des
masques au début de votre intervention
là aussi le gouvernement promet un
millier
deux masques et dans les semaines et les
mois à venir comment est-ce que vous
accueillez cette annonce hier soir du
premier ministre edouard philippe
les mots ne suffisent plus
il nous faut des actions concrètes et
justifiée nous réclamons des preuves de
ces de ses commandes de masques et les
preuves de livraison de ces masques aux
professionnels de santé
point barre nous allons faire un recours
le lundi 30 mars auprès du tribunal
administratif pour demander et exiger du
gouvernement ses preuves on en veut bien
croire le gouvernement
on n'est pas mais on veut des preuves
maintenant ça suffit et autres requêtes
un qui a été débouté
c'est la demande de dépistage massif
olivier ferrand assuré que la france
fera 50 mille tonnes par jour d'ici la
fin avril est ce que c'est insuffisant
selon vous on sait que l'allemagne par
exemple en titre de comparaison ces cinq
cent mille tonnes par semaine mais ça
avec 50000 t ce faire il met fin avril
c'est bien bien trop tôt prêtre tu as
bien trop tard il faut le faire il faut
le généraliser dès maintenant et il faut
prendre les moyens
il fallait le pelé prendre d'ailleurs ya
un mois où il ya trois semaines au début
du confit naulleau il faut prendre les
moyens pour avoir des thèses dépistage
qu'il faut généraliser à tout le monde
c'est pas simple c'est simple à
comprendre
vous avez une pathologie infectieuse
vous dépister les malades avec un test
simple qui a d'égalité et des
inconvénients mais vous faites un test
pour savoir si les patients sont malades
et si les patients sont malades soit
vous choisissez de les comptes de les
mettre en confinement soit vous
choisissez de les traiter pour ceux qui
ont des antécédents comme un diabète
l'hypertension suffisance que spirent à
toi etc
mais vous restez pas sans rien faire et
j'ai simplement en les confinant c'est
pas possible
mr seydoux et ses joues merci c'est le
mot de la fin daniel laquelle d'albertas
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes chirurgien orl et
résident du syndicat smaer